there's a new breed of fake guru out
there and they're clever they're smart
they know that you guys know that the
people written the Lambos and all that
kind of stuff they're scams so what do
they do well now they appeal to that by
calling them out they go oh yeah I'm
here to call out the fake gurus right
you saw this with Katie nine early on
everyone is sitting in front of
Lamborghinis and Ferraris and trying to
get you to attend a free Amazon training
so we came to an alley and we saw with
John Kriss Donny there are more scams
out there on the internet than there are
legitimate opportunities by far but now
we're faced with a new opponent this is
Kevin zing
he's calling he wants to put the fake
gurus out of business for all of you
gurus and self-proclaimed experts out
there you better watch out because I'm
about to give away more value in this
free channel than all of your standing
courses combined it's time to take that
rented Lambo back to the lot Wow look at
Kevin really dunk on these gurus he
really doesn't like these fake gurus huh
he's tired of their Lamborghinis and
these next two days I want you to really
reflect on the goals that you have for
your life and just boy did you just
notice that though he talks about
reflect on what you really want and then
he puts a Lamborghini and a mansion so I
want to answer a question today who is
Kevin Zhuang and what does he teach on
one of his funnels where he's gonna end
up trying to sell you a two thousand
dollar course you know he says other
gurus teach you how to build stores like
these and then it says scam scam scam
don't build brands that scam I'll show
you why the websites above don't build
customer trust and loyalty build brands
that crush the trust building websites
below are what you'll create step by
step with me okay so he's he's tired of
the scams he's tired of the fake gurus
he's sick of it
guys he's sick of it he won't have it
that's why you need to go to him instead
of the other groups guru Kevin over the
fake gurus right that's what he's trying
to tell you but what is Kevin saying
actually done well according to his
Instagram he's gone from 0 to 20 million
dollars in one year but what what shops
did he build what brands did he build he
wouldn't build a brand that scams no no
no no no he would never do that
well we look at his height video so I
decided to share my secrets there's a
little slip-up at fifty nine where he
shows us a web page but we can actually
zoom in computer enhance you know
Newport apparel dot my Shopify dot-com
that's one of his pages okay well who's
that
Newport apparel let's look at these
people well they're out of business and
they have a customer complaint
oh this business has a pattern of
complaints regarding refund and exchange
issues no not cabot no don't build
braids at scale but there's some related
businesses who's this Dixon leather
who's Dixon leather well oh look at this
a pattern of complaints regarding
customer service issues and there's
several other web pages that are
affiliated with this they're all under
the same address that's why they're
affiliated they're all under forty one
logistics Boulevard Walton Kentucky this
one has a Better Business Bureau rating
of F this couldn't be related to Kevin
Zane but oh my gosh it is because it's
the same address as Newport apparel
which Kevin Zhuang is advertising in his
own hype video huh interesting
but there's another point of connection
on one of Kevin Zhang's Facebook pages
it says he owns Dixon trading company
LLC now Dixon Trading Company LLC Dixon
leather are they necessarily connected
no until we go to Dixon leathers web
page which by the way is now to lead it
all these websites are now closed but if
we go look at a screenshot that someone
grabbed it says this site is owned and
operated by Dixon Trading Company LLC
huh isn't that the page that Kevin's
hang on yes it is
this website is operated by Dixon
leather so it's owned and operated by
Dixon trading company operated by Dixon
leather
interesting okay my gosh the walls are
closing in on old Kevin Zane here what's
going on tell me the truth for all of
you gurus and self-proclaimed experts
out there and you better watch
out what's going on here well dick some
leather if you guys don't know was
selling up these these these leather
jackets right or leather belts leather
gloves and their whole website was all
about real leather not bulls right
because Kevin Zhuang you know right this
is this is right up Kevin things alley
you know saying that he's not going to
give you the fake stuff he's gonna give
you the real stuff right for all of you
gurus and self-proclaimed experts out
there you better watch out and all his
all his uh you know advertising says
these are leather jackets but when you
go and you look at the complaints
they're not leather they're polyurethane
which is basically plastic and it turns
out the Better Business Bureau yeah they
contacted him in july 2019 and told him
to not call his stuff leather but they
never changed it and although that
website has now gone out of business
there's a new website that looks very
similar it's called longhorn leather
shop it's up right now and what's the
front page say leather not bull oh yeah
Kevin Kevin don't build brands that scam
I'm not gonna teach you how to build
brands of scam right and what is it oh
it's the exact same thing as Dixon
leather
so in conclusion guys this guy who's
saying oh yeah I'm putting the fake
goobers out of business I'm not gonna
teach you how to run scam stores right
I'm not gonna teach you how to run scam
stores
this is mr. Dixon leather this is mr.
Newport apparel this is mr. tactical
grizzly all of them terrible reviews in
the Better Business Bureau they're being
investigated they're shut down this is
who you're buying a course from dude
these guys are ridiculous man giving
people polyurethane jackets under the
guise of it being leather it's absolute
garbage but you know what if you decide
to go and buy Kevin Zane's course
because of course he is selling of
course two thousand dollars you can look
forward to this a warning tonight a
variety of online retailers are using
fake Illinois addresses consumers say
these shops do not deliver merchandise
since products made from poor quality
material or it even doesn't look like
what's advertised the Better Business
Bureau had complaints about several
websites computer enhance
unfortunately the world of e-commerce
education is full of scammers pretenders
and outright Liars I'm sure you've seen
their ads all over the place and I bet
many of you have even been their victims
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the common
[Music]